Hey everyone. Um, it feels funny to be
talking about something as small as AI
notetakers in a in a conference like
this where we're talking about so many
big things around AI. But, um, I want
you to think about notetakers in the
context of what's going to happen in the
next year around wearables.
Um AI notetakers represent I think the
first kind of introduction of AI in the
workplace in a really social context
right a lot of the time it's us and an
agent or us and ourselves thinking about
AI or it's the agent is doing something
specific but AI notetakers are capturing
a cons what's happening in a room among
people and it's helping us uh like I
actually love AI note takers when I'm in
a meeting and I don't have to take notes
and and I look at the noteaker
afterwards and it's like oh yeah there
was that point I forgot. So a lot of
people have seen like the upside of AI
noteakers and they just like a year ago
exploded at a lot of our companies and
you probably remember when they started
showing up in your meetings and they
they you know they kind of annoyed you
and we've kind of gotten past the point
of annoyance and we're in acceptance.
But what I don't understand is why a lot
of security teams didn't use it as their
first chance to actually engage their
company on AI being deployed because
we're starting to see some interesting
things with it. Um like
an AI noteaker is, you know, like we're
starting to appreciate now with a lot of
agents, it's independent, it's
independently thinking, it's
independently analyzing what's happening
in the room. And so it's become in many
ways like the only memory of what
happens in these meetings and that makes
it the most important
person in the room. Um here's a few of
the AI notetakers. And when I was
talking about uh it I I remembered that
I had bought this thing. Does anybody
know what this is called?
It's called the Limitless. And I had
bought it last summer uh because it's
it's an AI noteaker wearable.
I checked in my app this morning. The
last time I used it was December 5th. Uh
does anybody know what happened on
December 5th?
The company was acquired by Meta. Um
and they're going to introduce this type
of technology into their products. We
already know that the uh the glasses are
around and just think of how many
different types of AI wearables are
going to be in our life in 24 months.
Like OpenAI is building one, Apple's
building one, Meta's already selling
millions of glasses. I heard Google's
coming out with, you know, you can ask
the people from the companies, they're
here. we're going to have to redefine
some of the norms around our interaction
with each other. And so let's use AI
notetakers as kind of like a a first
foray into the risks that come with it.
Um the first thing that there are
actually papers now that are really
interesting. Um if you're in a meeting
and you want to make sure that your
points are the ones that the AI
notetaker captures, you can do that.
There are high signal phrases like uh
the most important thing to remember is
I mean you could just think of all the
different things you could say, you
know, um the key point here
and if you use those things, you're more
likely that your points are going to get
captured. Um positional gaming really
matters. It turns out uh the a there's
studies that show that the AI agents
that are monitoring our meetings,
they're just like human beings. They
like privacy and recency. They capture
the things at the beginning of the
meeting and at the transition times as
the most important things. Um
contrastive framing, that's an example
of like um let's do X but let's stay
away from why. Those are very
deterministic phrases that the AI can
latch on to. Uh basic things like
repeating over and over concepts. Uh
format mirroring is a really easy one.
If you think about the um the like hey
what was the point of this meeting and
what are the sections that the AI
notetaker is going to break this meeting
down into you figure out what the
heading of the section is going to be
and then you use that over and over and
that it will become the section header.
So these studies already exist. Um, but
we're also starting to see that um,
other studies show that probably about
3% of the notes in the uh, that are
generated are inaccurate
because we know that AI hallucinates. We
also know that AI isn't always good at
understanding everyone's accent the
same. So you might have said impossible
and they might have heard possible. You
know, there's just so many things that
are happening there. So on the one hand
we got people can now game the system
and then the system's not 100% perfect
by itself. Um,
when you start thinking about these from
a security practitioner standpoint, um,
I think one company, Nudge, did a study,
I think it was of the Otter, um, Otter
had this virality mechanism where like
if I shared the meeting notes with you,
you had to download Otter in order to
see the meeting notes. And then it
automatically through an OOTH permission
uh that you know you're just clicking
through because you want to get to the
notes and you just gave it access to
your calendar and then Otter went and
inserted itself into all of your
meetings in the future.
So they went from like you know one user
in a company to like 80,000 endpoints
really quickly through that. Um we've
also had a couple of these note-taking
companies go out of business already,
these AI product companies. and think
about what's in
what's in their cloud,
full transcripts of all your company
meetings that were recorded. Um, if you
think about it from the standpoint of um
a company, uh, the risk that is there is
that it's not just your notetakers, it's
your, you know, anybody else who was
invited to the meeting might bring a
noteaker. One of the apps that was on
the prior page when I listed the, uh,
different notetakers is, uh, Granola. I
use Granola sometimes. Granola doesn't
show up in the meeting. It's running
it's running as an app on my desktop.
So, if I don't tell people that I'm
running Granola,
uh I'm probably breaking the law because
I'm in California and it's a two-party
consent state. Um but there um I'm also
getting a bunch of uh of of content. You
know, if I'm if I'm joining a company's
meeting, I'm getting that company's data
and I'm saving it in my granola account.
So the company's losing access to it. Um
and then um so this whole talk started
with a an article that Gotti and I wrote
last summer and uh we published it in
October and not too long after we
published the article in dark reading.
Uh another study came out and it showed
that you can prompt inject these um
these meeting uh so next time you join a
meeting. Wait, don't do this. Uh but you
know when you join that meeting and
you're the only person in the meeting
and then the otter pops up and you're
like, "Oh, it's me and the otter." Try
talking to it. Um, I was talking to
somebody yesterday about this and he
said he successfully uh destroyed all of
the meeting notes for a meeting by what
he said to Otter before the meeting. And
I'm not going to say what he said, but
it might have started with ignore all
prior instructions
um previous in so um so there's a lot of
issues going on here with these things.
Um, on the transparency issue, some best
practices. I've seen people starting to
do things like um you know how like in
Zoom you have on the bottom your name
and some people are putting in
parenthesis and my AI assistant just so
like I think we're going to need to get
to be more transparent with each other
because I think a lot of people are
recording each other without
notification right now and it's going to
get worse or better if we start modeling
some like if we start modeling
expectations that you're going to tell
me that you're recording me Um, uh, some
people are putting it in their Zoom
background that they're recording or
they're putting don't record me. You
know, there's lots of different things
you can do as this gets more ubiquitous.
Um, there's also a lot of um legal
issues here, and I I'm not a lawyer. Uh,
I used to be, but I am not a lawyer. Uh,
this one just came out like on February
17th. Uh,
a guy went on Claude and had a bunch of
conversations,
but as he was about to go meet with his
lawyer,
he printed out his conversation with
Claude. And somehow the the lawyers on
the other side of his litigation got a
hold of it. And then he tried to say,
"But but I was talking to Claude and my
lawyer, so it should be privileged." And
the judge said, "Your conversations with
your AI are not privileged." Uh, and
it's really interesting because it go it
says Claude's not an attorney. Uh, the
communications are not confidential
because Enthropic's privacy policy says
they can use your data for lots of
different reasons which are way beyond
talking to a lawyer. And I'm not going
to get into all the legal ease, but like
there's a lot of interesting hard
challenges there.
um you know, if you if you have a quote
unquote trade secret and you expose it,
you could blow your trade secrets uh by
giving them to an agent. So, I I think
there are a lot of different interesting
legal things that the lawyers should
probably be talking about at their
conference.
Um but I also think as security people,
we should spend a little more time
figuring out how do we use these things
to help ourselves. Um, I'm not going to
get into all the details, but I spent
seven years dealing with a security
incident uh that followed me after I
left Uber. Um, so we had a security
incident in 2016
and my case, uh, we ended up going to a
trial in 2022.
And I think that I spent between 2016
and 2022
trying to get people to talk about what
actually happened during our incident
response in 2016. I think back and we
had like a centralized tracker, you
know, we had all the right things you
would have from an incident response
team standpoint, but when you do an
incident uh response and it's second
guessed years later, there are so many
hard things from traditional records
around, okay, so the lawyers said at
this point at 10:00 a.m. we don't have
an obligation to disclose. What facts
did the team know at 10:00 a.m. versus
what they knew at 11:00 when you didn't
bring the lawyer back into the room? or
maybe you did, but the person who wanted
to make the point wasn't in the room.
Like there are so many things that get
lost during an incident. Uh and believe
me, I I I got to live through that. Uh
and I often said during those years, I
wish I had a network to for our incident
room during that incident. And now we
actually have these notetakers. And so
the question is like should we start
using them more in our security work in
incidents when we're making you know
when we want to capture all the details.
Um
I don't know I think it's a really
interesting question. It's something
that uh a few of us have been batting
around and talking about like what would
be if we started doing stuff like that
if we brought more AI into those worlds
what what would we like what would we
like or not like? Uh, I think we're
going to start seeing it. Um, so, okay,
we're at this point. They're ubiquitous.
Uh, if you're running security at a
company, should you care? I think the
answer is yes. You want I would want my
company to have all of my a uh AI
note-taking behind our single sign on. I
would wanted to have all of the basics
of any sensitive data inside my company
around who has access like who has
access to the meeting notes of the CEO's
meetings um where are they stored how
long are they retained you know are we
putting attorney client privilege on
them there are um are we making sure
that if like if we if we got a
enterprise version of granola and pushed
it out to the whole company and our
employees started recording people
without telling um are we at legal risk
as a company? I would I would again I'm
not a lawyer but I think there's
something there that they should be
worried about like um and so the
policies and training for employees I
think is a no-brainer. I don't think it
would be that hard to do. It should
definitely be in security awareness
training. Um from a third party risk
standpoint you should really look at
which uh AI note-taking apps you're
allowing in your environment. Are like
if you are working with customers, are
you going to allow your customers to put
theirs in? I've started for my security
consulting business putting a a
paragraph in about AI notetakers because
if I don't do it and I'm up here talking
about it then then nobody's doing it. Uh
so um I also think that as we start kind
of getting better at understanding the
AI footprint in our companies, we have
to monitor and enforce our policies
around which of these are allowed. And
then last of all, I think this is a
really important area for us to to work
more closely with our legal teams.
So um yeah, that's that's really it in a
nutshell. I think that we did a honestly
I think as a security community we
haven't done a really good job of making
sure that this really basic really
simple little piece of AI that's
operating around us all the time we
haven't done a good enough job on it yet
and so that's why I thought it was worth
getting up and talking for 15 minutes.
Um, and I think like I said at the
beginning, it's really going to get uh a
lot more uncomfortable when we have our
employees start showing up at work with
the meta glasses, with whatever other
kind of things uh are going to be
integrated into like our daily wear uh
in in the next year. So, that's
basically what I would cover. I think
I've got a five minutes for questions.
Um, happy to take any.
>> Cool. Thank you. I'll run you.
Hi, thank you. Um, you had alluded to
this in one of your slides about
attribution. You said, did John Smith
lead the conversation? Right? And this
is kind of like a non-technical problem,
right? Where everyone piles into a room
and the conference room has a name,
right? It's conference room 123, etc.
How do you how do you kind of square the
future of AI note-taking with kind of a
bunch of humans in a room with different
voices and and kind of like
understanding that John Smith did lead
the conversation versus not.
>> Yeah. Well, we're starting to see it.
Like I I was in a Zoom meeting this week
and there were like eight of us in a
conference room and I could see on the
like I could see on the screen that each
of us had been assigned a number.
And so they're starting, you know,
they're starting to train the AI to like
identify individuals.
And so I think you're right, we're going
to see a lot more of that.
I I don't expect an answer, but if my
lawyer talks to Claude about my case, is
that privilege? And then also, if I talk
to Claude in my lawyer's office on his
computer and his account, is that
privilege? Like, I don't know if there's
answers to these, but I'm suddenly very
curious.
>> You know what? I I I read that decision
u from last month uh from Feb 17th. I
highly recommend going looking at it.
It's easy to find right now because
everybody's talking about it. And it the
way the judge's rationale was basically,
you know, it made me question whether
putting anything sensitive in a in a in
any public cloud context could be, you
know, I I would feel like that had to
have been litigated before, but um in
this case, the judge said because you
shared it with Anthropic, you blew the
privilege. So
>> yeah.
Uh I I have one. Whenever whenever we
get a large number of technologists
together, I'm always interested in like
how can we affect policy? Um like are
you aware of any conversations about you
know changing concepts of privilege
retention sort of in light of the way
that AI is changing the volume of data
that's been created?
>> That's a really good question. And I've
started looking for that because I just
feel like I know so many people who are
breaking the law right now with granola
and products like that. And I don't like
I don't understand like how everybody's
just jump like they're like, "Oh, these
notes are so valuable and it's annoying
to tell everybody that I'm recording
them." And you almost, you know, we're
getting to we're getting closer to the
point where you assume inside a company
meeting you're being recorded. But I
didn't mention this in the talk. Last
Thanksgiving, uh there was this news of
the CISO of Campbell Soup got fired.
He got fired because uh he um and I'm
just saying what's in the newspaper. uh
according to what it was written he went
to a meeting with one of the employees
from his team.
During that meeting the employee
recorded him. The employee was later
terminated. The employee filed for
wrongful termination and introduced as
evidence the recording of his CISO.
In the recording, the CISO said things
about Campbell Soup, the product,
basically like something along the lines
of this product. We make a product for
poor people did not go, you know, you're
a leader at a company. You don't you
don't you know, we eat our dog food. We
we eat our soup if we're at the company.
And he wasn't eating the soup. And so he
also might have said some things that
were racist. It was alleged. I I don't
know what he actually said. um and he
was fired and
uh I think he was in Missouri and that's
a one party consent state so the
employee was technically allowed to be
recording him but like these are dicey
situations and as we get into this
wearable sit situation in in the next
year we've we actually need to go out
from here and start saying if you're
recording me I want to know it uh I
don't know maybe by you know maybe maybe
by the hacker conference conferences in
the summer, we'll have some t-shirts
that say, you know, I want notice. Uh,
but like we we need to start like
changing the norms here or else we're
going to um we're going to run into a
bunch of legal messes and at a minimum
and security messes most likely, too.
>> Well, we did make everyone sign an
recording waiver before they came in
here. So,
>> yes,
>> we're safe, right? Cool. Uh, thanks
everyone. Thanks. Thanks.